The fight was over a pair of Gymshoes. At night, on the south side of Chicago, and this is what came of it. One teenager faces years in prison. Another, a boy of just 15, is dead. The incident might not have even made the news, except the victim was the grandson of a long-saving congressman. At a press conference, that congressman, Danny Davis, did something unusual. He grieved, not just for his own grandson, but for his grandson's killer. I grieve for my family. I grieve for the young man who pulled the trigger. I grieve for his family, his parents, his friends, some of whom will never see him again. It is so unfortunate when these tragedies continue to occur and re-occur, and somehow or another,
这场冲突起因于一双运动鞋。那天晚上，在芝加哥南部，结果酿成了悲剧。一名青少年面临多年的牢狱之灾。另一名年仅15岁的男孩则不幸丧生。这起事件甚至可能都不会登上新闻，如果受害者不是一位资深国会议员的孙子的话。在一次新闻发布会上，那位国会议员丹尼·戴维斯（Danny Davis）做出了一种不寻常的举动。他不仅为自己的孙子感到悲痛，也为他孙子的杀人凶手感到悲痛。我为我的家人感到悲痛。我为那个扣动扳机的小伙子感到悲痛。我为他的家人、他的父母、他的朋友感到悲痛，其中一些人将再也见不到他了。每当这些悲剧不断发生、再次发生时，实在是令人遗憾，不知何故，
our society has not been able to find and exact the answers and solutions. The solutions we do have often produce more disputes than results. Conservatives call for harsher sentencing and better policing. Liberals want gun control and more social service programs. One thing's clear, even as we argue, people are dying. In 2016, Chicago had the highest number of killings in two decades, 762 people were murdered. What can be done? Well one community group has an unusual idea. It believes perhaps violence can be stopped with a breath, a few moments, and a tiny tweak to the way we think. Very, very often, if they could only take back five minutes of their life, a lot of these kids, a lot of the people that are locked up would have a very different life.
我们的社会一直未能找到并给出准确的答案和解决方案。我们现有的解决方案往往带来的争议多于实际结果。保守派呼吁更严厉的判决和更好的治安。自由派则想要枪支管制和更多的社会服务项目。有一点是显而易见的，即便我们在争论不休，人们仍在不断死去。2016年，芝加哥发生了二十年来最多的命案，有762人被谋杀。我们能做些什么呢？有一个社区组织提出了一个不同寻常的想法。他们相信，也许通过一个呼吸、片刻的暂停，以及对我们思考方式的一点点微调，暴力就能被制止。很多很多时候，如果他们能够哪怕收回生命中的五分钟，许多这样的孩子，许多那些锒铛入狱的人，将会拥有截然不同的人生。
Thinking our way out of crime, this week on Hidden Brain. Our story begins with another death on the south side of Chicago. One night in the fall of 2007, Amadou Sis, a young PhD student from Senegal, was walking home after a gathering on the University of Chicago campus. He was confronted by a stranger, 17-year-old Demetrius Warren. Warren stuck a stolen 22-calibre handgun in Sissis chest and tried to take his water bottle and backpack. And I don't think anyone knows exactly what happened. Maybe Amadoucis didn't let
本周的《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我们将探讨如何用思维摆脱犯罪。我们的故事从芝加哥南部发生的另一起命案开始。2007年秋天的一个晚上，来自塞内加尔的年轻博士生阿马杜·西斯（Amadou Siss）在芝加哥大学校园的一场聚会后步行回家。他遭到了一名陌生人的拦截，这人是17岁的德米特里·沃伦（Demetrius Warren）。沃伦将一把偷来的22口径手枪抵在西斯的胸口，试图抢走他的水壶和背包。我想没有人确切知道当时发生了什么。也许阿马杜·西斯没有那么快
go of his backpack or his water bottle quite quickly enough and then Demetrius Warren pulled the trigger and shot him basically at point blank range in the chest and killed him. This is Jens Ludwig. He's an economist at the University of Chicago, focusing on social policy and crime. He says the murder of Amidu Siss was a very definition of senseless. If they thought about it for even one second, it is very hard to imagine that anyone would think that it was a good idea to shoot someone at point blank
放开他的背包或水壶，然后德米特里·沃伦就扣动了扳机，几乎在零距离朝他的胸口开枪，将他杀害。这位是延斯·路德维希（Jens Ludwig）。他是芝加哥大学的一名经济学家，主要研究社会政策与犯罪。他说，阿马杜·西斯的被杀完全是“毫无意义”的定义。如果他们哪怕思考了一秒钟，也很难想象会有人觉得，用一个书包和一个水壶——这两个转售价值最多也就值个几美元的东西——去换取在零距离枪杀某人的机会是一个好主意。如果他们哪怕思考了一秒钟……事实证明，芝加哥的许多谋杀案之所以发生，正是因为有人没有停顿那一秒钟。我们去了法医办公室，查阅了相当数量的案件档案，这些档案记录了年轻男子被谋杀的经过。哈罗德·波拉克（Harold Pollack）是一名公共卫生研究员，与芝加哥大学犯罪实验室合作。
range in exchange for a book bag and a water bottle that would surely have a resale value of not more than a couple bucks at best. If they thought about it for even one second, it turns out many motors in Chicago occur because someone didn't stop for that one second. We went to the medical examiner's office and we just reviewed quite a number of case files in which young men had been murdered. Harold Pollack is a public health researcher who works with the end of the University of Chicago Crime Lab.
在阿马杜·西斯被杀后不久，哈罗德决定弄清楚这座城市发生众多凶杀案背后的原因。在这么多的案件中，你读到这个故事时会发现，法医报告通常相当简短。你知道的，会有很多关于肉体遭遇了什么的细节，但通常只会有一段简短的报告来描述发生了什么。在许多这样的案件中，你读完后会忍不住说，哇，我简直不敢相信竟然有人因此丧命。这里面根本没有什么东西的分量能够接近一条人命的分量。大多数人可能会想象，杀戮的发生是因为黑帮火拼、冷血复仇或有预谋的谋杀，但档案却显示了一长串微不足道的轻微冒犯：
Not long after the killing of Amidu Cis, Harold decided to figure out what was behind the many homicides in the city. And so many of these incidents, you just read the story, you know, medical examiners report is typically, you know, pretty brief. You know, there would be, you would get a lot of details about what happened to the physical body, but usually there would be, you-paragraph report about what happened. And many of these cases you would just read it and say, wow, I just can't believe that someone ended up dead. And there was nothing at stake here that was anywhere near the stakes of a human life. Where most people might imagine that killings occur because of a gang hit or cold-blooded revenge or premeditated murder, the records reveal the laundry lists
有人踩了别人的鞋子、或者偷了一件外套、或者说了句侮辱的话，而正是从这微小的火星开始，事情升级成了暴力和谋杀。哈罗德采访过被关押的年轻人，他们告诉他，后悔感几乎和愤怒来得一样快。实施凶杀的孩子，在五分钟后，自己就开始想：哇，这竟然是因为一件夹克。你知道的，非常非常多的时候，如果他们能够哪怕收回生命中的五分钟，许多这样的孩子，许多那些锒铛入狱的人，
of slights, someone stepped on someone else's shoe or stole a coat or lobbed an insult, and from that tiny spark, things escalated into violence and murder. Harold is interviewed incarcerated young men who tell him that regret comes almost as fast as anger. The kid who committed the homicide, five minutes later, himself, he's thinking about, wow, this was over a jacket. You know, very, very often, you know, if they could only take back, you know, five minutes of their life, a lot of these kids, a lot of the people
将会拥有截然不同的人生。正当延斯和哈罗德百思不得其解，为什么小小的摩擦会失控演变成这样时，他们意识到自己正在探讨一个本质上属于心理学的问题。为什么人们会做出不理智的行为？为什么人们做事会如此不经大脑？紧接着，他们脑海中闪过了一个灵感。芝加哥南区和西区的男青少年并不是唯一一群做事不经大脑的人。我们所有人都会这样。
that are locked up would have a very different life. As Jens and Harold puzzled over how minor incidents could spiral out of control, they realized they were asking a question that was fundamentally psychological. Why do people do irrational things? Why do people act so unthinkingly? And then they had a flash of insight. Teenage boys on the south and west sides of Chicago are not the only ones who act without thinking. We all do it.
心理学家甚至为这种行为起了一个专业术语：自动化（Automaticity）。我们在生活中进行的许多思考都带有很强的剧本化和自动化特征。如果没有这些对某些事物无需多加思考的快速反应，我们就无法度过日常生活，部分原因是因为那样做太耗时间了。如果有人立刻冲到我面前，且对我的安全构成了直接威胁，我必须做出自动化的反应，
Psychologists even have a term for this behavior. Automaticity. A lot of our thinking that we do in life is very scripted and is very automatic. And we couldn't go through life if we didn't have very quick reactions to things that we don't give a lot of thought to, partly because it just takes too much time. If someone gets in my face right away and there's an immediate threat to my safety, I have to respond automatically
如果我在做出反应前还要停下来进行一番精神审判，这对我来说并没有太大实用价值。换句话说，我们经常几乎是在无意识中行动。门就在我们面前，我们就把它打开。我们不会去想“我该怎么开这门”？我们只是顺手做了。如果有人打了我们，我们可能也会同样迅速地回击。哈罗德回忆起发生在自己身上的一起事件。他在一家汉堡王（Burger King），排队时被别人推了一下。哈罗德不是个好斗的人，但在那一瞬间，他确实感到了回击的原始冲动。
if I sort of stop and conduct a little mental oj trial before I respond, that's not going to be very functional for me. In other words, we often act almost unconsciously. Our door is in front of us and we open it. We don't think how do I open this door? We just do it. If someone hits us, we might also, just as fast, hit back. Harold remembers an incident that occurred to him. He was an aburga king and someone else in line shoved him. Harold's not a fighter, but for a moment he felt a primal urge to lash out.
我感受到了那种灼热感，然后我提醒自己，我是一个书呆子气的中年教授，我应该直接把餐盘扔了然后走开，但当时确实……我确实动过那个念头。我想，如果我是……如果17岁的我，很可能会落得个脑袋开花的下场。哈罗德没有打架，因为在付诸行动之前，他针对当时的情况和后果思考了一秒钟。哈罗德和延斯不禁琢磨：这个简单的步骤——三思而后行——会不会就是解决芝加哥暴力犯罪的良方呢？很大一部分暴力问题——至少这是我们做研究时的假设——
I felt that burning sensation and then I kind of reminded myself that I'm a nerdy middle-aged professor and I should just throw my tray away and move on, but it was, you know, I thought about it. And I think if I were, if the 17-year-old me might well have ended up, you know, with the gash in his head. Harold didn't get into a fight because before he acted, he thought for one second about the situation and the consequences. Could it be Harold and Jens Wunderd that this simple step, think before you act, could be a solution to violent crime in Chicago? A lot of the violence problem, at least this was our hypothesis doing the study.
芝加哥街头的许多暴力问题并不一定是由坏人引起的。它们是人们在冲动之下做出错误决策的结果。我们的假设是，如果我们能找到某种有前景的干预措施，帮助人们避免其中一些常见的判断和决策错误，这或许有助于解决暴力问题。研究人员花费了多年时间来研究如何让人们减少自动化行为，改变他们脑海中的剧本。其中一种经常被使用的技术被称为CBT，即认知行为疗法（Cognitive Behavioral Therapy）。这个理念是通过培养新的剧本和新的习惯来解决问题。
A lot of the violence problem on the streets of Chicago is not necessarily driven by bad people. It results from bad decisions that people make in the moment. And our hypothesis was if we could identify some promising intervention that could help people avoid some of these common kind of judgment and decision-making errors, that that might be helpful in producing the violence problem. Researchers have spent years studying ways to get people to behave less automatically, to change the scripts in their head. One technique that's often used is called CBT, Cognitive Behavioral Therapy. The idea is to develop new scripts and new habits to address problems.
例如，一个酗酒者可能需要练习选择一条不同的下班回家路线，一条不经过他最喜欢的酒吧的路线。一个有愤怒管理问题的人可能需要练习在回应前数到10。一个容易抑郁的人可能需要对自己说，悲伤的情绪可以是短暂的。改变我们的行为可以改变我们的思维，而改变我们的思维可以改变我们的人生。通常情况下，这种疗法是由训练有素的专家通过一对一的方式进行的。
An alcoholic, for example, might need to practice taking a different route home from work, a route that doesn't go by their favourite bar. Someone with anger problems might need to practice counting to 10 before responding. A person prone to depression might need to talk to themselves about how feelings of sadness can be transient. Changing the way we behave can change the way we think, and changing the way we think can change our lives. Mostly, this kind of therapy takes place one-on-one with a trained expert.
你如何才能在庞大的规模上，对芝加哥一些最贫困、最暴力社区的数千名儿童实施这种干预呢？你不可能把他们全叫来做一对一的心理治疗。事实证明，延斯和哈罗德发现了一个名为“青年指导”（Youth Guidance）的当地组织，该组织已经在尝试类似的做法。它在社区学校内部为孩子们提供一种低成本的心理治疗。这个项目没有什么花哨的地方。孩子们定期与辅导员进行签到沟通，讨论各种问题，并努力培养新的习惯。
How do you do this on a large scale with thousands of kids from some of the poorest and most violent neighborhoods in Chicago? You can't bring them all in for one-on-one psychotherapy. As it turned out, Yens and Harold found a local group called Youth Guidance that was already trying something similar. It was offering kids a kind of low-budget psychotherapy within their neighborhood schools. There was nothing fancy about the program. Kids checked in with counselors regularly, talked about issues, tried to develop new habits.
延斯和哈罗德想要弄清楚，这种低成本的努力是否能够在打击犯罪的大规模行动中发挥作用。他们希望对该项目进行严格的测试。他们想要像医学研究那样，进行一项随机对照研究。他们不想被自己的希望和直觉所误导。我们基本上有一群出于好意的市政府和州政府，以及一群出于好意的
Jens and Harold wanted to find out if this low budget effort might be effective on a mass scale in combating crime. They wanted to test the program rigorously. They wanted to conduct a randomized controlled study the same way it's done in medicine. They didn't want to be misled by their hopes and intuitions. We basically have a bunch of well-intentioned city and state governments and a bunch of well-intentioned
非政府组织（NGO），他们在不断创新，随着时间推移尝试了许许多多不同的事情，但他们并没有以一种能够让我们真正进行严格研究和评估哪些方法有效的方式来做这件事。如果没有关于我们的哪些创新真正有用的良好反馈，我们就很难朝着正确的方向前进。在现实世界中进行随机对照研究非常困难，但哈罗德和延斯与“青年指导”组织合作，对该项目展开了研究。
NGOs out there, innovating and trying lots and lots of different things over time, but not doing that in a way where we can actually rigorously study and evaluate which things are working. And without good feedback about which of our innovations are actually helpful. It's very hard to move in the right direction. Performing a randomized controlled study in the real world is very difficult, but Harold and Yens teamed up with Youth Guidance to study the program.
现在，这个特定的项目被称为BAM，即“成为一个男人”（Becoming a Man）的缩写。研究人员列出了一份年轻男子的名单，他们都住在芝加哥最危险的一些地区。有成千上万的青少年可供选择。我们基本上是通过抛硬币来决定哪些孩子获得该项目的名额，哪些孩子没有。在我告诉你他们的发现之前，我想带你深入了解这个项目，以便你能看到
Now, the specific program is called BAM, short for becoming a man. The researchers compiled a list of young men living in some of the most dangerous parts of Chicago. There were thousands of teenagers to choose from. We basically flipped the coin to decide which of the kids would get offered the program and which wouldn't. Before I tell you what they found, I want to take you into the program so you can see
它是如何运作的。BAM把那些勉强糊口、大多数人成绩低于平均水平的年轻人聚集在一起。近40%的人曾被捕过。他们辍学并最终入狱的几率极其之高。他们住在诸如西加菲尔德公园（West Garfield Park）这样的社区。这里是犯罪猖獗的芝加哥暴力犯罪率最高的地区。就在最近一个随机的30天时间里，西加菲尔德公园就发生了34起抢劫案、18起殴打案、15起袭击案、6起性侵案以及一起谋杀案。这里就是奥尔高中（Orr High School）BAM项目的所在地。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。奥尔高中给人的感觉像是一个
how it works. BAM brings together young men who are barely scraping by, most have a de-average. Nearly 40% have been arrested. Their chances of dropping out of school and ending up in prison are extremely high. And they live in neighborhoods like West Garfield Park. It has the highest rate of violence crime in crime-ridden Chicago. In just one random 30-day period recently, there were 34 robberies in West Garfield Park, 18 batteries, 15 assaults, 6 sexual assaults, and one homicide. This is the home of the BAM program at Orhyschool. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Or high school feels like a place that was
建立在宏伟梦想之上的地方。它由传奇建筑师密斯·凡·德罗（Mies van der Rohe）的事业部于20世纪70年代初设计。它规模庞大，但其互联的建筑群原本旨在让预计入学的2000名学生不至于感到难以适应。也许起初它发挥了作用，但那个梦想中的学校已经不复存在了。奥尔高中现在正苦苦挣扎。大片区域空无一人。随着孩子们逃往特许学校，注册人数急剧下降。空旷的走廊里回荡着回音。一辆警车在外面空转着引擎。
built on big dreams. It was designed in the early 1970s by the firm of the legendary architect Mies van der Rohe. It's huge, but interconnecting clusters were supposed to make it less overwhelming for the 2000 students expected to attend. Maybe it worked at first, but that dream school no longer exists. Or is now struggling. Vast sections said empty. Enrollment is dwindled as kids flee to charter schools. The empty hallways echo. A police cruiser idles outside.
孩子们穿过金属探测器进入学校。在一间教室里，BAM辅导员拉里·波茨（Larry Potts）正等待着学生的到来。拉里把他的工作视为一种使命。我对此充满热情。我的意思是，我在这片社区生活了45年。我以前是这个社区的警察。对我来说，除了去帮助触及每一个孩子之外，没有任何利益可图。拉里说，现在激励他的部分原因是他作为警察时所见到的景象，当时他能够窥视
Kids walk through a metal detector to enter school. In one classroom, Larry Pots, a BAM counselor, waits for students to arrive. Larry thinks of his job as a calling. I'm bored into this. I mean, I've been in this community for 45 years. I used to be a police officer in this community. And there's nothing for me to gain, but to help reach every kid. Larry says part of what motivates him now is what he saw as a cop when he could look
身边人们的生活。这些家庭中存在大量的精神疾病。当你接到家暴报警出警时，你会看到家中有精神疾病。你会看到许多瘾君子。你会看到人们进监狱，家庭支离破碎，没有母亲和父亲。你会看到大量的贫困。人们没有工作，没有技能，
into the lives of the people around him. There's a lot of mental illness in the families. When you would make domestic calls, you would see mental illnesses in the homes. You would see a lot of addictions. You would see people going to jail and being torn apart without having a mother and father. You would see a lot of poverty. People not having jobs, not having skills,
无法工作来照顾他们的家人。但我见过的最糟糕的事情之一是，当人们犯下错误时，根本没有办法去改写这个错误。所以这就是拉里现在在做的事情，努力阻止孩子们犯下那些他们无法纠正的错误。每周，有11名年轻人前来参加他协助主持的辅导课程。
not being able to work and take care of their families. But one of the worst things that I've seen is that when people do make mistakes, there's no way to rewrite that mistake. So that's what Larry's doing now, trying to keep kids from making those mistakes, they won't be able to correct. Each week, 11 young men come in for a counseling session that he helps to lead.
中午刚过，年轻人鱼贯而入，接着就到了签到时间。课程总是从这个签到环节开始，简要总结每个人生活中正在发生的事情。大家必须谈谈自己在身体、理智、情感和精神上的感受。年轻人给出了真实而坦诚的回答。我叫沙万特（Shavante），我在身体上签到。我感觉很好。
Shortly after noon, the young man file in, and then it's time for a check-in. The sessions always begin with this check-in, a brief summary of what's going on in everyone's life. People have to talk about how they feel physically, intellectually, emotionally, and spiritually. The young men give raw and honest answers. My name is Shavante, and I'm checking in physically. I'm feeling good.
我用我的名字签到，我叫詹姆斯（James）。在身体上，在身体上，我很累。昨晚搬箱子搬了一整夜，没睡多少觉。我有选修课，我一直在思考周五的数学测试，我一直在努力学习，想把我的分数从B提升到A，因为我知道这能大大提高我的总体成绩。签到环节花费了很多时间，我发现自己忍不住瞥了一眼手表，但随后我意识到
I'm checking in my name, James. Physically, physically, I'm tired. Didn't get that much sleep last night carrying boxes all night. It's election, I've been thinking about this math test on Friday, I've been studying the hard to push my seat up to a B and eat a better dent to A, because I know Ducca bring my grade up a lot. The check-in takes a lot of time and I find myself glancing at my watch, but then I realize
这些孩子的生活中缺乏大量的情感支持。拉里说，他们需要空间去倾诉、去被倾听，最重要的是，去感受到他们并不孤单，有人在听他们说话。有人在支持他们。这是我们在小组中真正珍视的事情之一，那就是人与人之间的信任。老师们总是来学校，校长们总是来学校。校长们总是来学校
these are kids without a lot of emotional support in their lives. Larry says they need space to talk, to be heard, and most of all, to feel they're not alone, that someone is listening. Someone has their back. That's one of the things that we really value here in our groups is again the trust of people. Teachers come to the school all the time, principals come to the school all the time. Prince always come to the school all the time
然后又离开了。孩子们知道这一点，他们身边没有一个每天都可以依靠的人。签到结束后，年轻人通常会讲故事、进行角色扮演，然后做各种练习。这一天，他们做一个“信任步行”的练习，其中一个学生闭上眼睛，由搭档引导绕过教室里的各种障碍物。
and they're gone. And the kids know this and they have no one that can depend on every day. After the check-in, the young men usually tell stories, role play, and then do various exercises. On this day, they do a trust walk where one student closes his eyes and is led around various obstacles in the classroom
当学生们在教室里走动时，我注意到了一些事情。那些闭上眼睛的年轻人一开始看起来很紧张，但随后他们放松了。他们只需要专注于朋友对他们说的话。与此同时，他们的搭档则专注于朋友告诉他们的指引。走这边，走这边，走这边。与此同时，他们的搭档则专注于保护他们。在短暂的瞬间里，他们不再只顾自己，而是去照顾别人。这是一种被迫产生的亲密感，但很快，它就变得真实起来。
by a partner. I noticed something as the students are walking around the classroom. The young men who have their eyes closed start out looking tense, but then they relax. All they have to do is focus on what their friend is telling them. Their partners meanwhile focus on what their friend is telling them. Go here, go here, go here. Their partners, meanwhile, focus on protecting them. For a brief moment, they're not looking out for themselves, but for someone else. It's a forced kind of intimacy, but very quickly, it becomes real.
当练习结束时，空气中弥漫着真正的快乐和自豪感。一切都很好，因为结束了，空气中弥漫着真正的快乐和自豪感。感觉很好，因为我在做这件事，但我其实在做之前就已经在脑海中把房间可视化了。所以我已经知道我在哪里了。我感觉自己好像在洗手间附近。所以我知道我在一扇窗户旁，我闻到了披萨的味道，我知道我在这边。另一个BAM的练习是“抢球”。学生们再次被分成两人一组。其中一人拿到一个球。另一人被告知他有30秒的时间去把球拿过来。几乎每次，第二个学生都会试图把球抢过来。时间到后，辅导员会问：
When it's over, there's a real happiness in the air and a sense of pride. It's all good, because it's over, there's a real happiness in the air and a sense of pride. It felt good because I was doing it, but see, I visualized the room before I did it. So I already knew what I was at. I felt something like I'm in my ass. So I knew I was at a window, I smelled the pizza, I knew I was over here. Another bad exercise is the fifth. Students again are divided into pairs. One of them is given a ball. The other is told he has 30 seconds to go get the ball. Almost always the second student tries to wrestle the ball away. When times up a counselor asks,
你们有没有想过，其实可能有一种更简单的方法？比如直接开口要这个球呢？比如直接开口要这个球呢？在某种程度上，这些练习看起来几乎有点老土。它们教导的是历久弥新的道理：信任你的朋友，守望相助，三思而后行。但这些都是我们所有人都会忘记的教训。我们都需要被提醒，特别是当我们碰巧是个17岁的少年时，学会慢下来。BAM项目极力避免说教式的口吻，不去告诉年轻人该怎么做。它主要试图向他们展示，他们其实有多种选择。
did you ever consider they might have been an easier way? What about just asking for the ball? What about just asking for the ball? On one level, these exercises seem almost hokey. They're teaching age-old lessons. Trust your friends, look out for each other, think before acting. But these are lessons we all forget. We all need reminding, especially maybe if we happen to be 17, to slow down. The band program tries hard not to be preachy and tell the young men what to do. It's mostly trying to show them that they have options.
如果我们告诉这些孩子们“绝对不能打架”，对于他们所处的现实世界来说，这未免太不现实了。我们必须帮助他们建立这样一种观念：你知道的，有时你可能不得不打架。但你的工具箱里还有什么别的？你知道的，你首先会伸手去拿哪个工具？拉里摆出了一个奥尔高中年轻人可能会面临的困境。好吧，如果你是一个17岁的孩子，你有一件非常漂亮的夹克，你穿着它放学回家，你不能当那种让别的孩子觉得可以随便过来抢走你夹克的人。你必须表现得强硬。因此，他们需要有一种非常现实的需求来震慑周围其他人的掠夺行为。
If we tell these kids you're never fight, that's just so unrealistic for the world in which they live. What we have to help them with is the idea, you know, you may have to fight sometimes. But what else you got in the toolkit and, you know, which tool do you reach for first? How are a lays out a dilemma that a young man at or might face? Well, if you're a 17-year-old kid and you have a really nice jacket and you're walking home from school with it, you can't be the kind of kid that other kids think they can just come and take your jacket. You have to be tough. And so there's a very practical need that they have to deter the predations of other people around them.
如何在不表现出软弱的情况下避免打架？BAM项目的一名学生说他无时无刻不在面临这种困境。我……相反，身体上我感到高兴、紧张、充满期待。你知道的，因为我已经是一个……坎特雷尔（Cantrell）和我走到室外，以便他能告诉我他的故事。他一直在惹麻烦。有一段时间，他被送往一个住院行为健康项目，以帮助他控制怒火。坎特雷尔说，即便在那里，他有时还是会失控。
How do you avoid fights without communicating weakness? One of the students in the band program says he faces this dilemma all the time. I'm on an incontrary, physically I'm happy tense, pons waiting. You know, because I'm already a... Cantrell and I stepped outside so he could tell me his story. He's been in and out of trouble. For a while, he was sent to a residential behavioral health program to help him get his anger on the control. Even there, Cantrell says, he sometimes lost it.
我有一个室友，他挺好的。他习惯在马桶座圈上尿尿，而且不肯清理干净。所以我想他也有火气，然后我跟他说了这事，但他还是继续这么做。于是我们就会争吵、打架，我就会大脑一片空白，然后开始动手之类的。每次发生那种事时，我从不考虑后果。坎特雷尔给我的印象是强硬与脆弱的奇特结合体。他身材消瘦，经常盯着地面发呆，但他的内心深处潜藏着一根发条。那根发条随时都可能弹开。就像有一次，一些孩子在学校外面试图抢他的夹克。
I had a roommate, and he was like, he was real nice. He used to pee on the toilet seat and they want to clean it off. So I guess he had anger too and then I told him about it so he kept doing it. So then we used to argue fighting not just blank out and just start fighting and stuff like that. And then every time that happens I never think about the consequences. Cantrell strikes me as a curious mixture of toughness and vulnerability. He slender and stares at the ground a lot, but there is a coil inside him. That coil can unspring in an instant. Like the time some kids try to steal his jacket outside school.
对坎特雷尔来说，这不仅仅是一件夹克的事。这是一个不尊重的问题。其他的孩子在说：你是个懦夫，我们可以对你为所欲为。对我来说，作为一个男人，我所有的……这不是什么好听的话，但我把自己看作是一个有尊严的男人，我有我的自尊，我感到他们践踏了我的尊严，没有尊重我。自我，我觉得他们贬低了我的尊严，不尊重我。当他们对我做那种事，严重伤害了我的尊严时，为了……找回尊严并重拾荣誉，我想给他们一个教训。坎特雷尔为这起事件生了一整晚闷气。
To Cantrell it was more than just about the jacket. It was a sign of disrespect. The other kids were saying, you're a punk, we can push you around. To me, like as a man, all I was, it's not a good thing to say, but I look at myself like a man as pride, my prideful and myself, and I feel like they downgraded my pride and they respected me. and myself, and I feel like they downgraded my pride and they respected me. When they did that to me, and they heard my pride real bad, and to like, give, like, earn my pride back and feel back honored, I want to teach them a lesson. Cantrell smoldered all night about the incident.
第二天在学校里，他袭击了一名他认为参与了围攻他的团伙的学生。我很生气，所以我直接冲过去，打了他的脸，我大概打了至少三遍，现在公交车都看着呢。事实证明，坎特雷尔搞错了。他袭击的那名学生根本没有参与其中。他意识到这就是他需要改变的行为。他需要做出更好的决定，慢下来，思考。做出慢下来、思考的决定。坎特雷尔告诉我，当他最近看到一个家伙在跟他的女朋友说话时，他的怒火再次涌上心头。同样，他把这视为不尊重。在他看来，那个学生是在说：你这个男人连自己的女朋友都看不住。
The next day at school, he attacked a student he thought was part of the group that had jumped him. And I was mad, so I just ran into him, hit him in his face like I had him at least like three times, now buses look. It turned out Cantrell got it wrong. The student he attacked hadn't been involved. He realized this was the kind of behavior he needed to change. He needed to make better decisions, to slow down, to think. a decision to slow down, to think. Cantrell told me his anger surged when he recently saw a guy talking to his girlfriend. Again, he saw it as disrespect. In his mind, the other student was saying, you aren't man enough to keep your girl.
但坎特雷尔没有像原本想要的那样痛击那个学生，而是走过去和他谈了谈。那个学生说他对坎特雷尔的女友没有任何兴趣。他们只是在闲聊。事情就这么简单。突然之间，一场可能以拳脚相交告终的事情，以一个点头化解了。我必须克制自己。我知道这会激怒我，但作为男子汉，我必须考虑后果。
But instead of punching the other student as he had wanted to do, Cantrell went up and talked to him. The other student said he had no interest in Cantrell's girlfriend. They were just chatting. That was it. All of a sudden, something that could have ended in blows, ended with a nod. I got to break myself down. I know it gets me, but in my man, I got to think of the consequence
在我做某事之前。我会深谋远虑。当我向坎特雷尔道别时，我感到有些不安。我有一种感觉，他正处于刀刃边缘。我能看出他几年后会顺利毕业并且过得很好，但我也能看出他可能会惹上麻烦。这就让我们回到了延斯·路德维希和哈罗德·波拉克——那两位研究BAM项目有效性的研究人员。他们的发现完全反映了我在坎特雷尔身上看到的情况。BAM管用吗？它能让像坎特雷尔这样的年轻人远离监狱吗？嗯，答案是既管用，又不管用。让我们从好消息开始。还记得控制自动化行为的想法吗？嗯，正如哈罗德所说，它起作用了。当孩子们参与BAM时，他们对危险情境的自动化反应减少了。
I thought I'd do something. I think far ahead. When I say goodbye to Cantrell, I feel uneasy. I have the sense he's on a knife edge. I can see him graduating and doing well in a couple of years, but I can also see him getting into trouble. And that brings us back to Jens Ludwig and Harold Pollack, the researchers who were studying the effectiveness of the BAM program. What they found precisely mirrors what I saw in Cantrell. Does BAM work? Will it keep young men like Cantrell out of jail? Well, the answer is yes and no. Let's start with the good news. Remember the idea of controlling automatic behavior? Well, it's as herald that works. When kids are participating in BAM, they're responding less automatically to dangerous situations.
事实上，针对BAM的对照研究结果表明，它的效果好得令人惊掉下巴。当学生们参加BAM时，逮捕率骤降了44%。延斯这样说道。当我看到最初的一组结果时，我从椅子上摔了下来，这组结果表明，参加“成为一个男人”项目的孩子们的逮捕率比未参加者低了44%。
In fact, the results of the control study of BAM showed that it worked jaw-droppingly well. While students were in BAM, arrest rates plummeted by 44%. Here's Yens. I fell off my chair when I saw the initial set of results, indicating that the arrest rates for kids in the becoming a man program were 44% lower than the non-participants.
这是暴力犯罪逮捕率的大幅下降。延斯称这些结果令人震惊，几乎堪称奇迹。还有更多好消息。BAM甚至似乎对学业也有帮助。孩子们更有可能来学校。他们在学年末更有可能继续注册在籍。他们辍学的可能性更小。他们挂科的可能性也更小。延斯和哈罗德现在可以确切地说，BAM项目确实有效。对于缺乏好选择的年轻男子来说，这是一场巨大的成功。但遗憾的是，这里有个问题。
These are massive reductions in violent crime arrests. Yens calls the results stunning, almost miraculous. And there was more good news. Bam even seemed to help with school. Kids were more likely to come to school. They were more likely to be enrolled at the end of the school year. There's less likely to have dropped out. And they are less likely to fail their classes. Jens and Harold can now say with certainty that the BAM program works. It's a huge success for young men without many good options. But sadly, there is a catch.
一旦年轻男人们失去了控制，结束了学校生活，也结束了BAM项目，暴力率的下降就无法维持下去了。项目结束后，他们的犯罪率与对照组不相上下。因此，如果我查看他们项目结束一年后的逮捕率，并将他们的逮捕率与项目结束后同一年对照组孩子们的逮捕率进行比较，我真的看不出有什么区别。哈罗德和延斯不知道为什么BAM里教的东西在项目结束后无法持久，
The reduction in violence doesn't stick once young men lack control are done with school and done with BAM. They are offending at the same rates as the control group after the program is over. So if I look at there are rest rates in the year after they're done with the program, and I compare their rest rates with kids in the control group in the same year after the program is over, I really don't see differences there. Harold and Jens don't know why what's taught in BAM doesn't last once the program ends,
但这其实合乎情理。我们所有人都需要不断提醒自己过去听过的许多建议：做个深呼吸，用客观的眼光看待事物，如果感到沮丧就跟朋友聊聊。延斯说，改变行为很难，特别是对那些经历过创伤生活的孩子而言。但他仍然觉得，该项目带来的乐观理由多于悲观理由。我受过经济学训练，我对一个社会项目是否值得去做这一问题的思考方式是，我先考虑项目的成本，然后再考虑它对帮助孩子和整个社会所起的作用。以及社会效益的价值是否足以证明项目成本是合乎情理的，而对高危儿童为期一年的暴力参与度44%
but it actually makes sense. All of us need reminders of advice we've gotten many times in the past. Take a breath, look at things in perspective, talk to a friend if you're feeling down. Yen says it's hard to change behavior, especially for kids who've led traumatic lives. But he still feels the program offers more reason to be optimistic than pessimistic. I'm an economist by training and the way that I think about whether a social program is worth doing or not is I think about what the program costs and then I think about what it does to help kids and society as a whole. And whether the value of the social impact is enough to justify the program cost, and a 44%
的降幅，为社会带来的效益轻易就超过了项目的成本。因此我们估计，这一干预措施的效益成本比甚至可能高达31比1。对于那些保持无犯罪记录的年轻人来说，即使只有一年，也有切实的益处。如果我有一年时间犯罪较少，那么即使我在那之后犯罪，你知道的，它仍然会累积成对我而言破坏性较小的犯罪记录，如果人们在讨论这个人是否需要被关押在安全设施里之类的事情时。当然，当你遇到
reduction in violence involvement for at-risk kids for one year, generates benefits to society that easily outweigh the program costs. So we've estimated that the benefit cost ratio might be as high as 31 for this inter-rengeon. And there are tangible benefits to the young men who stay crime-free even if it's just for a year. If I have a year where I have fewer offenses then even if I commit offenses after that it's still you know it's accumulating into a less destructive record for me if people are talking about does this person need to be held in a secure facility or something like that. Of course when you've met
像坎特雷尔这样处于刀刃边缘的年轻人时，你会对他们抱有更多期望。一份破坏性较小的犯罪记录是不够的。这些场景尚未以任何无可挽回的方式彻底失败。我是这样看待它的：一项科学研究发现，你可以建造一种新型桥梁，一座既好又坚固的桥梁。它能够
young men like Cantrell on the knife edge, you want more for them. A less destructive criminal record isn't enough. These scenes haven't failed in any irreparable way as yet. I see it like this. A scientific study has found that you can build a new kind of bridge, one that is good and strong. It could
将这些年轻人带向成功的成年期。但那座桥只建了一半。在奥尔高中的每一场BAM课程结束时，学生们都必须进行签到离开（check out），说出一个浮现在他们脑海中的词。当我听到那些词时，我多么希望那座桥能够合龙完工。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）制作，由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队成员包括玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）、勒内·克拉尔（René Clarre）、雷娜·科恩（Reyna Cohen）和克洛伊·康纳利（Chloe Connelly）。我们本周的原创音乐来自拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布卢伊（Ramtin Arablouei）。我们今天的幕后英雄是阿尔法·德拉博（Alpha Drabo）。阿尔法是我们部门的IT专家，当我们的计算机莫名其妙地表现得像计算机时，他就是那种能给我们带来宽慰的声音。谢谢你，阿尔法，感谢你分享你的
take these young men to a successful adulthood. But that bridge is only halfway done. At the end of every bam session at Orhai School, the students have to check out to say one word that is on their minds. When I hear those words, I want that bridge completed. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and edited by Tara Boyle. Our staff includes Maggie Penman, René Clarre, Reyna Cohen and Chloe Connelly. We had original music this week from Rampteen, Arab Louis. Our Ranzang hero today is Alpha Drabo. Alpha is the IT specialist for our department and he's a voice of reassurance when our computers inexplicably behave like computers. Thank you Alpha for sharing your
技术专长和善良。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并在当地公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请告诉一位不知道《隐藏的大脑》的朋友我们的节目。在社交媒体上告诉我们你向谁推荐了我们。我们一直在寻找新听众来发现我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。好的。信任在我们的嘴里。对此金额感到满意。
tech savvy and your kindness. For more Hidden Brain, follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, please tell one friend who doesn't know about Hidden Brain about our show. Tell us on social media whom you've tapped. We're always looking for new people to find our show. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. Okay. Trust in our mouth. Happy with that amount.
太棒了。而且带有那个金额。我们来这里是为了离开这里。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。你 这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Awesome. And with that amount. We're here to get out of here. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了。带着这笔钱。我们来这里是为了离开这里的。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。你 这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。